Salut les Mentalos ! Aujourd'hui on va mélanger mémoire, mathématiques et mentalisme !
Vous m'avez demandé plusieurs fois si j'avais une technique, une méthode, pour retenir les formules de mathématiques.
Là dedans !
La réponse est oui !
Et je ferme ce volet pour qu'on arrête de me regarder par la fenêtre.
On va encore utiliser ce bon vieux cerveau pour créer des faux souvenirs à base d'images.
Mais là, beaucoup plus simple que ce qu'on a pu voir dans des méthodes généralistes.
Quand c'est appliqué aux maths je trouve que la méthode est assez... assez cool.
J'allais dire "sexy", mais oui, elle est assez sexy en fait ! [rires]
On va créer des images pour ce genre de formules mathématiques, sauf qu'on a pas besoin d'avoir une règle définie.
Les images parleront d'elles mêmes ensuite, et la scénette qui vous reviendra sera traductible, très facilement.
Vous allez le faire vous même. Alors je vous montre le processus pour arriver à créer les vôtres.
Ça c'est facile. Je viens d'écrire une formule au hasard.
J'ai écris quoi...: x=(a²+3b), divisé par racine carré de -9. Ok.
Pour cette formule et pour d'autres j'utilise quand même un code universel pour deux, trois choses.
Le signe "=" quand c'est divisé, les "( )", le "²", la racine carré...
Ca pour moi à chaque fois c'est les mêmes images, c'est le même code.
"=", ce sont des barres parallèles.
Beaucoup de mnémotechniciens utilisent cette image.
Pour le divisé, c'est bien de diviser un lieu en deux.
Par exemple une maison avec un étage, une salle de spectacle avec un balcon...
Tout ce qui est en haut est au dessus du divisé.
Et tout ce qui est en bas est en dessous du divisé.
Pour la racine carré, je vous recommande de choisir toujours la même image, quelque chose qui enferme.
Quelque chose de gros comme... une maison, comme un hangar, ou alors un tivoli, un parasol géant... Ce que vous voulez.
Un "²", je l'associe à un carré, donc à une boite, à une caisse, à un coffre fort... Ce genre de choses.
Et pour tout ce qui est "+" et "-", j'utilise des charges, vous allez vite comprendre.
Je reprends la formule d'exemple: x= quelque chose.
Alors le "x", il faut que je trouve quelque chose qui commence par la lettre x, et qui me fasse penser après spontanément à ce x.
Ce sera à chaque fois mon point de départ pour cette formule.
Donc pour ce "x" là, spontanément je vais prendre Charles Xavier. Déjà parce que c'est Charles Xavier et que c'est le mec des X-Men.
Donc comme ça mon "x", il sera bien défini.
Je ne vais pas l'imaginer dans son fauteuil, néanmoins je vais l'imaginer en train de faire des barres parallèles.
Il est au premier plan, dans mon image, Charles Xavier, en train de faire des barres parallèles.
Et là j'ai mon "x=".
Il est maintenu.
Comme c'est moi qui vient de créer l'image, je sais que je pourrai la retraduire plus tard.
Mais il ne fait pas des barres parallèles n'importe où, il fait des barres parallèles sur la scène de l'Olympia.
Et devant lui, il y a tout l'Olympia.
Et là, mon regard change. Et je vois tout l'Olympia, donc toute la fosse, (ce qu'on appelle "la fosse " c'est le bas) et le balcon.
Sur l'étage de mon balcon, se trouve un ananas géant !
Il est géant, il est énorme et il est enfermé dans une boite transparente.
Donc j'ai un ananas géant, enfermé dans une boite transparente, c'est a².
Et à coté de cet ananas, sur sa droite, (parce que dans ma tête je lis toujours de gauche à droite), il y a 3 brebis. Trois petites brebis !
Et elles sont en train de sourire. Elles ont un smile, mon pote !
Il est énorme !
Et comme elles sourient, ça veut dire qu'elles sont positives. Donc ça veut dire que j'ai + 3 brebis.
Donc j'ai +3b.
Parce que j'ai pris le "b" pour brebis !
Ensuite à l'étage inférieur, c'est-à-dire dans la fosse de l'Olympia, je vais avoir une grande toile de tente, une immense toile de tente, c'est un peu un tivolien-toile de tente, je ne sais pas trop ce que j'ai fait dans ma tête... [rires]
Et sous cette toile de tente, on peut voir pleins d'œufs, qui sont complètement pétés. Pleins d'œufs qui sont cassés.
Des œufs cassés, des œufs cassés, des œufs cassés...
Donc "œuf", pour moi c'est 9.
Et si vous utilisez une table de rappel, je vous propose quand vous avez comme ça une constance, de prendre l'image de votre table de rappel.
Et ils sont cassés, c'est négatif, c'est une énergie négative, donc je sais que c'est -9.
Et là, si je reprends mon image de Charles Xavier, sur des barres parallèles, sur la scène de l'Olympia, en face de lui au balcon il y a un ananas géant dans une boite transparente,
et à coté il y a trois brebis qui sourient, et juste en dessous, il y a une espèce de toile de tente géante avec des œufs écrasés partout.
Là, je peux traduire directement que x=... alors au dessus: a²+3b
En en-dessous, donc divisé par racine carré de -9.
Pour les parenthèses, vous pouvez utiliser vos symboles. Moi je prends souvent les frères Bogdanov.
Quand il y a en un, c'est le début de la parenthèse, quand il y en a un deuxième, c'est la fin de la parenthèse. [rires]
Trouvez des choses comme ça qui marchent en binaire, pour les parenthèses, c'est cool.
Je m'en suis servi dans ma scolarité pour toutes les formules. Même les fonctions, les dérivés, des choses comme ça qui ont l'air compliqué. Des très grosses formules.
Ça fonctionne très très bien.
En plus de ça, un endroit où vous n'avez pas le droit aux formules... Je ne vous dis pas de tricher attention !
Si vous marquez sur un petit bout de papier la première image d'une formule, vous allez voir que toute la scène va vous revenir assez facilement.
Si vous avez d'autres méthodes ou d'autres astuces pour mémoriser les formules mathématiques, parlons en dans les commentaires, c'est toujours bien.
Plus ça va, plus vous vous donnez des conseils dans les commentaires entre vous, et je trouve ça super en fait pour la culture, la connaissance, et l'échange.
Bravo les Mentalos !
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo alors n'oubliez pas l'image mentale... Pouce en l'air !
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner à la chaine avant de partir, c'est très important, on est presque à 100 000.
Et oui j'avais fait une promesse pour les 100 000 abonnés... promesse que je vais tenir.
Je suis déjà en train de travailler dessus.
Si vous ne connaissez pas cette promesse, regardez la première Foire Aux Questions que j'ai fait sur la chaine.
Allez, rendez-vous demain à 17H, car le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an ! [hurle]
Ciao !
Je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre à la Garenne-Colombes. C'est la date la plus proche de Paris, si jamais vous voulez venir. Sinon il y a toutes les dates de tournée sur mon site.